foreign
when I was in senior year university
this was around 2004.
I was in one of those classes where the
teacher would read the slides word for
word as part of a three-hour lecture oh
oh you all know what I'm talking about
okay cool
I ended up doing all right in the class
by catering to my own learning style
after a little bit of experimentation I
found that playing a video game during
this lecture a game like Tetris or in
this particular case Zelda diminished
cap help me pay attention because the
primary way I engage with information is
by listening
and this meant that the teacher's voice
with matching text were a distraction
for me anyway I was at the back
listening and participating mind you
but one day this teacher decided to call
me out
he stopped the class and said excuse me
are you playing video games in my class
and then I said uh I am sir but this is
the way that I learn
and then he said there's no way that
you're learning anything
and then I said uh sir I'm not
interrupting I am learning and I'm even
participating and then he said no I
don't want you playing video games in my
class
and then I said sir
I'm gonna place this Game Boy Advance on
the table
repeat your last two sentences word for
word
and then I'm going to pick up this Game
Boy Advance and keep playing
and then he said I don't think you can
do that and then the class went
oh you can picture that all right cool
so
I placed my Game Boy Advance on the
table
I looked him right in his eye repeated
his last two sentences word for word and
then I picked up my Game Boy Advance and
kept playing
and then you know what he said
all right carry on
so since that day I become a professor
myself
a video game design
and I'm convinced that there's
absolutely something that video games
can teach the world of Academia like how
they can cater to human learning how
they can enhance online instruction and
how they can provide clear objectives
let me explain
humans can take in information in Three
core ways audio text and video now as I
demonstrated earlier I'm an oral learner
which means I prefer to take an
information via sound
and some studies show that when two or
more of these channels are used learning
gains are higher but
there's a cache
now I was struggling to pay attention in
this class because of something called
cognitive overload which can happen when
audio text and video aren't different
enough when used together
so when the audio of my teacher match
the excessive text on his slides
my brain was overloaded
teachers who use technology in the
classroom need to ensure that each
channel is complementary otherwise
students are going to have difficulty
transferring information from working
memory to long-term memory now
I fixed the problem for myself by
essentially using the teacher's voice as
the soundtrack for the game I was
playing
and this brings me to my first point
video games by Design
are a complex blend of audio text video
and interactivity that can intensify
Focus
that was the point of my PhD
and because of their enjoyment Factor
these components of video games can help
with something our students desperately
need in the classroom
motivation
now
at their best video games can immerse us
focus our attention and provide clear
objectives with demonstrated output you
know how well you're doing every step of
the way and video games can teach
multiple things
simultaneously like
there's this class I teach
game design where I like to use a video
game called Virginia
now in Virginia you play as Ann Tarver a
newly hired FBI agent who is tasked with
internally investigating someone
who just happens to be the only other
female agent in the precinct and this
game is based on a true story
now on the surface I'm using Virginia to
teach game design
but I'm also using the mechanics of
video games to trick students into
exploring complex Concepts like history
sexism racism corporate culture
and tokenism while we play this game
together
to me effective instruction merges
theory and practice each week in this
class I like to pick a unique video game
that matches the game theory and
sprinkles in a couple of Life takeaways
we play the game together and talk about
it and then the students have to go and
make video games themselves
and this all happens wait for it
online
[Laughter]
guess what coven forced everyone to join
me teaching online and most schools
struggled but there are many examples of
effective online instruction in unlikely
places like YouTube streams Netflix
programming and believe it or not
Amazon's twitch
now as you probably know twitch is an
online streaming platform where people
can watch other people play video games
but it can also be used to learn how to
paint with Ergo Josh
learn how to play piano with Juan or
piano
learn how to code with Rocio tome and
even how to cook meals with yarumichan
uh-huh yeah real
and twitch had an average of 2.78
million concurrent viewers in 2021 now
that's a lot of motivated Learners if
you actually think about it
one of my favorite classes to teach
online is a class called Esports
broadcasting where
I'm essentially just using video games
to teach students how to professionally
present themselves online using a free
piece of software called open
broadcaster software or obs
here I teach them how to connect any
available camera to the software
add white balance
and color correction to help that image
pop
use on-screen text to complement the
video
and compress any available microphone to
make it sound and look exactly like what
they're accustomed to consuming online
and the same processes that hook viewers
on Twitch are the same processes school
should use to learn how to engage
students online and globally that should
be one of their objectives shouldn't it
hold on
what are the objectives of a
post-secondary education anyway
and what could education overall learn
from video games which clearly say start
here do these things and then obtain
these things
now if the goal of a post-secondary
education includes students getting a
job in the same thing they went to
school for guess what schools are
failing more than half of graduates do
not get jobs in their field of study
that'd be like enrolling in Chef
training and then graduating to start a
job in data analytics
why not just enroll in data analytics
you could
grow with Google has an online program
promising you a job in data analytics
starting at seventy four thousand
dollars a year and that program is free
to start
epic games offers a pathway to become a
developer with its Unreal Engine for
interactive 3D development a field that
they say has gone up 601 percent and is
paying people 57 percent more than the
average salary for clarity their Unreal
Engine is the same tool used to build
fortnite and the same tool used to build
some of the backgrounds behind the
Mandalorian
at no cost to use
are y'all hearing all these near free no
fee examples I'm giving you
University in particular is mad
expensive the cost of university has
gone up
twelve hundred percent since 1980.
to me
to me there's not a single job trade or
discipline that doesn't in some way
connect to the video games industry
there are dentists like Dr August de
Oliveira who are using augmented reality
to see the roots of your teeth while
working on your teeth
psychologists are using virtual reality
to help you overcome a fear of spiders
and broadcast technicians responsible
for filming a dragon flying over a live
stadium full of people as part of a
League of Legends Esports broadcast
video game Technologies are embedded in
all of these
and that must mean that the video games
industry is not just made of players
but made of you
now I'm not suggesting that video games
replace classroom instruction settle
down internet
[Laughter]
I'm advocating for the components of
video games especially the engaging ones
to be ported into classroom instruction
because the audience the students
clearly understand the media there are
roughly 3 billion video game players
worldwide
video games contain the blueprint for
engaging education because of the way
that they cater to human learning a
complex story interwoven with learning
content and a bit of artificial
intelligence for difficulty and balance
online instruction can be enhanced if
schools turn to top streaming platforms
and streamers to learn how to
effectively engage students online
and the objectives for Education overall
need to be as specific as a video game
so that those who are enrolled have a
clear line of sight to where they're
headed
if we can start showing students how
their passion for playing connects to
their Futures we will have done our jobs
the next generation of teachers are
those who can connect the path of study
to profession via passion
oh and one last thing about the playing
of video games
there's a 2022 study suggesting that the
playing of video games is associated
with heightened cognition
faster reaction times improved working
memory and modifying the cortical
networks associated with the process of
playing
and that
is what I should have said to that
teacher thank you
[Applause]